c'est un match qui a opposé le mouvement
social le plus important de la vème
république le président élu en 2017
les gilets jaunes versus emmanuel macron
comment s'est déroulée cette
confrontation et qui a gagné c'est pas
grand chose cette affaire de j du jour à
concerne petits joueurs
[Musique]
tout commence en octobre 2018 avec une
hausse des prix du carburant
suite à une augmentation des taxes
gouvernementales une vidéo diffusée
alors par une inconnue
jacqueline moreau et visionné plusieurs
millions de fois la chasse aux véhicules
disait on continue des appels à
manifester se multiplient avec un
symbole on a tous un gilet jaune
la bagnole foutez là en évidence sur le
tableau de bord toute la semaine la fin
jusqu'au 17
les réseaux sociaux ont permis une
coordination semaine après semaine de
ces mouvements de ces groupements éclaté
comme ça qui se rassemblaient à droite à
gauche à travers le pays il ya un énorme
élan populaire qui a pris le port
totalement le pouvoir le 17 novembre
2018 des rassemblements et des blocages
de gilet jaune ont lieu dans tout le
pays
le ministère de l'intérieur dénombre
trois cent mille manifestants en france
il france qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
d'entendre
en dehors de tout appareil traditionnel
dents dehors de tout syndicat et la
france a lu mon oral du pays andin ça a
duré une journée
il faut savoir en effet ensuite revenir
à la normale les manifestants décident
pourtant de se donner rendez vous le
samedi suivant pour un acte ii
le début d'une longue série le pouvoir a
sous-estimé la puissance du phénomène
des gilet jaune tout le monde là
sous-estimée puisqu'en fait on est face
à un mouvement qui prend des formes
inédites m'appartiendra de prendre des
décisions supplémentaires mais elles ne
seront jamais des reculs le chef de
l'état au début se dit que ça va passer
or ça va durer beaucoup plus longtemps
que tous les scénarios qui était à ce
moment-là prévu après deux semaines de
manifestations
les revendications de gilet jaune évolue
au début il luttait contre pouvoir
d'achat ensuite il ya eu des
revendications d'ordre politique de
mettre en place le référendum a dit si
hâtive et citoyenne mais beaucoup ont
voulu animer un mouvement
insurrectionnel
le pouvoir est pris de court aussi parce
que à la tête du ministère de
l'intérieur on trouve et christophe
castaner et qui est un novice et un
ministres mis à l'épreuve le 1er
décembre lors d'un acte qui marque un
tournant dans le mouvement
l'acte iii l'arc de triomphe est
attaquée et mise à sac par
des casseurs le monde d'ailleurs au delà
de nos frontières assiste sidéré à ce
qui se passe
vous arrivez devant l'elysée vous faites
quoi
en dedans pour écouter ce sera la seule
solution c'est un gilet jaune pour
certains et on a d'autres qui finalement
s'en sont même servis puisque c'était
une manière aussi de de braquer son
mouvement
les projecteurs les médias etc
pour l'acte iv du 8 décembre le pouvoir
change de stratégie nous allons utiliser
une douzaine de véhicules blindés de la
gendarmerie
le pouvoir se barricadent un hélicoptère
qui est mis à la disposition du
président le 8 décembre pour qu'ils
puissent été exfiltré en cas de problème
c'est à dire qu'on s'attend au pire le
maintien de l'ordre a été mise à mal
pendant pendant un horizon était
parfaitement déborder la mobilisation
des gilet jaune ne faiblit pas deux cent
mille personnes sont encore dans les
rues chaque samedi
le salaire d'un travailleur au smic
augmentera de 100 euros par mois je
demanderai à tous les employeurs qui le
peuvent de verser une prime de fin
d'année à leurs employés les heures
supplémentaires seront versés sans
impôts nous annulerons en 2019 la hausse
de csg
je prends ma part de cette
responsabilité et président annonce plus
de 10 milliards de mesures
c'est quoi ces demies être un c'est vrai
il est plus riches n'en sont toujours
dans leur sphère et où ils ont rien à
payer
ils sont toujours protégés on ne s'est
jamais satisfait des annonces qui ont
été faites on va ce moment là essayer de
dire vous et un produit un problème de
pouvoir d'achat
[Musique]
au tout début du mouvement
les jaunes ont eu un soutien incroyable
des français les sondages l'ont montré
de manière très claire
le président est très affaibli en termes
de popularité par le mouvement est en
fait paradoxalement c'est un peu au fil
du mouvement qu'il va reprendre des
couleurs
toutes ces violences ont entamé le
capital soutien de l'opinion à l'égard
du mouvement il ya une guerre d'image
voilà une classe qui soutient sage j'ai
l'impression après l'impact de la lbd40
qui m'arrive à l'oeil personne ne peut
accepter l'idée que de façon totalement
en toute impunité des gens disent bas on
n'est pas d'accord
donc on va casser emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement met alors en place une loi
anti casseurs censée lutter contre les
violences lors des manifestations
il a une réponse sécuritaire qui va
quand même flatté une partie de
l'électorat plutôt de à droite il
atteint aujourd'hui une cote qui est
bien largement supérieure à celle du
début du déclenchement d'un généreux
le 15 janvier 2019
emmanuel macron se lancent dans le grand
débat national un tour de france pour
échanger et entendre les propositions
des français son entourage ne lui
conseille pas du tout cette solution
qu'il va décider c'est un peu aussi
aussi sur l'intuition stratégique de
s'appuyer sur les seuls élus qui ne
souffre pas du rejet des élites qui sont
les maires et il part dans un marathon
qui va un peu sidérée l'opinion publique
puisque ça va faire des cartons
d'audience plus de 92 heures de débat au
milieu des gens toutes les questions
sont ouvertes
t'as pas y avoir de tabou au moment où
on se parle l annonce du grand débat qui
a été lancé beaucoup ont joué le jeu
enfin c'était assez sidérant et il y
avait des réunions organisées dans les
mairies
dans des salles des fêtes un coucher
sans papiers les idées des uns et des
autres il ya une véritable mobilisation
et c'est vrai que cet exercice dans
lequel il a plutôt brillé va le remettre
en selle politiquement et
personnellement
le grand débat national s'achève les
gilets jaunes restent mobilisés
l'affrontement doit maintenant se jouer
dans les urnes avec les élections
européennes
le 26 mai 2019 l'idée d'une liste des
gilet jaune circulent dans les milieux
politiques ou se sont initiés à la
politique
ce conte animé ne paierait pas non plus
tous les outils tour pour asseoir un
discours pour un soir quelque chose qui
entraîne l'adhésion savoir combien nous
sommes dans ce pays à vouloir que ça
change
c'est ça que nous allons faire tout
simplement et c'est pour ça que nous
allons présenter des candidats du côté
du pouvoir c'est plutôt début vu comme
une bonne idée
s'il ya une liste gilet jaune à faiblir
le rassemblement national le réceptacle
un peu naturel de des mécontentements
pour ma part je renonce vraiment aux
européennes que peu importe la liste peu
importe le parti qu'en fait on a
certains qui ne veulent pas rentrer dans
les clous qui veulent pas créer des
listes entrer dans un courant politique
est récupérée
je pense que dans le ventoux type 2
droite vers macron la faire défiler
jourdain comptait on va vers l'ordre les
jeunes ont fait un flop avec des
résultats tout à fait médiocre les
listes se revendiquant du gilet jaune
réunissent 1% des voix le parti des
manuels macron arrive deuxième avec 22 %
après une année de mobilisation c'est
donc un match nul entre emmanuel macron
et les gilet jaune qui continue à se
rassembler une question reste ouverte
la partie est elle vraiment terminé
aujourd'hui le ministère de l'intérieur
ne communique même plus sur les quelques
manifestations qui ont encore lieu
certains samedis j'ai des gens qui
essayent du coup de se greffer à
d'autres mouvements ce qui a déclenché
le mouvement des gilet jaune
c'est l'idée dans la société que si vous
voulez obtenir des résultats c'est par
la violence qu'on peut y arriver il ya
un craindre clairement la violence
devienne un outil d'expression
à l'occasion de prochain mouvement c'est
ça les avatars de dg les gens